rude journée demain dans les écoles avec
le mouvement des instituteurs des
débrayages et des manifestations sont
prévues un peu partout à l'appel des
principaux syndicats à l'origine de la
grogne il y a le statut des maîtres
directeur publié ce matin au journal
officiel sous la signature de jacques
chirac
de quoi s'agit-il voici tout de suite
les explications des styles aussi avec
le décret le directeur change de
fonction et se retrouve à la tête de
l'école le ministère faisant clairement
de lui l'interlocuteur privilégié des
familles et des élus locaux
sur le plan pédagogique il reste
l'animateur de l'équipe mais avec un
nouveau pouvoir celui de décider
à ce titre il veille à l'application des
programmes et contrôle le travail des
maîtres
en revanche et contrairement à ce qui
avait été envisagé le directeur
n'intervient pas sur la notation de ses
collègues elle reste sous l'entière
responsabilité de l'inspecteur toujours
chargées des tâches administratives
le directeur apparaît en plus comme le
garant du service public
en clair il doit s'assurer que l'école
est ouverte aux élèves
même les jours de grève qui peut devenir
directeur toujours les instituteurs
volontaire mais plus seulement à
l'ancienneté comme avant 1981
une commission sera chargée de tester
ses aptitudes pour assumer ses nouvelles
responsabilités
sa formation et renforcer son salaire
augmenter environ 600 francs de plus par
mois
mais rien dans le décret ne prévoit de
le soulager d'une partie de
l'enseignement qu'il doit toujours
assuré et déjà quelques